he's a russian chess grandmaster and
former chess world champion he's
considered by many to be the greatest
chess player of all time he became the
youngest ever undisputed world chess
champion at age 22 he's Gary Kasparov
and here his top 10 rules for success
it's very important and I also come back
to chess to learn how to recognize your
own strengths and weaknesses this is in
fact the vital part of preparation for a
big match and for anything in life we
always try to study our opponents we
always try to try to study the
battlefield we always try to study all
the circumstances surrounding our
venture endeavor but very often we
forget to study ourself and this is very
important because any choice of a ground
for battle or you know type of strategy
we want to employ depends on our
recognition of our strengths and
weaknesses and this is a process of
constant evaluation because life is
changing very fast and our opponents
looking at our success studying it and
trying to be to be smart and outsmart as
eventual and we can look at the history
and just to find a number of situations
where the the inability to recognize
strengths and weaknesses led to an
eventual disaster
it's up to us what we want to do with
our success because you know eventually
you know if if we are successful we just
have to make a conscious decision what's
next and for me there was always the
next station because I I was it was
enough for me just to win I was wanted
to make a difference
it could also remind us of success of
Alexander Bell the inventor of telephone
who had a stack of notebooks where he
recorded every failed experiment so if
you work really hard you can find the
winning spot even you know in the midst
of your numerous failures
I think the ex speaker of US House of
Representatives Newt Gingrich hit the
right points when he said that
perseverance is a hard work you do after
you get tired of doing hard work you
already did I think that again from my
perspective patience it's it's your
ability to also accept failures because
very often today even from work from
kindergarten and of course all schools
and of course in colleges and of course
in at workplace and businesses we hear
all failure or failure you know failure
is nothing but failure while failure is
inevitable stepped over success if you
don't take a risk how can you you know
be sure about rewards especially if
you're looking for you know in a sub
sink bag and how you you know you you
want to do something that never happened
before you're looking for breaks
renovations it's like you know the sort
of a moon project something that you
know that is the something for blue
skies it means you have to enter
uncharted waters sort of untested
territories and again for me patience is
also a willingness to accept Taylor
defeat and to try again I learned that
you know it's never late to learn so
that's why you know it's even at age 37
you can learn from younger generation
and
that was a very important lesson not
only for the remaining five years of my
chest career but also for the food for
future years because not just I just
recognize that I mean flexibility is a
fundamental quality for success we
should learn how to trust our gut
intuition because in most of the stories
I looked at and in most of the clothes I
collected I didn't see people picking up
intuition as the crucial element of the
success while in my profession in chess
intuition is virtually everything
because chess some people don't
recognize it is a mathematically
infinite game the number of moves in the
game of chess all the moves contains 120
zeros which is more which is more than
number of seconds since the moment Big
Bang creative universe so how can you
find your way you know in this ocean of
possibilities and of course how a man
can fight a machine that could calculate
tens and tens of millions positions per
second intuition because it's all about
decision making process and we never
employ calculation as the as the main
tool it's 1% of calculation even less
and 99% of our understanding of our
ability to find intuitive ways to
compare incompatible material grocers
quality time versus material so
intuition plays a key role and we have
to trust our intuition our instincts
because in life also we have many
opportunities where we cannot foresee
all the consequences and there's only
one choice is just to trust your gut
because when we win we forget that there
are a lot of people who losing and those
who are losing their analyzing depth
they're trying to find out the reasons
for their loss the mistakes and if we do
nothing if we rest on low on our laurels
they'll come back after us next time and
I was on top of the world of chess for
20 years because I was very good even
relentless in challenging my own success
and did you go over all your games
once you succeed in the ones you fail
absolutely.i because even the game we
won always contained mistakes in their
courses it's inevitable it's I can
hardly imagine one Bruin game with no
mistakes which means that on both sides
yeah one Bosa but the trick is noticing
when the other guy makes him is
absolutely yeah if we won most likely is
because our ponent made their last
mistake but he made the last mistake and
he's definitely liked the game and he'll
find what we did wrong in the previous
stage of the game so what is important
is to find it first and to make sure
that next time when he is trying to
access surprisal to something we'll be
one step ahead I made a conscious
decision that Linares 2005 will be my
last professional and and today I played
my last professional game is there a
maximum age or can you be a chess
champion it if you want to be at 65 it's
very demanding game so you have to spend
time at the computer analyzing preparing
new ideas and then you just play under
this heavy pressure so we just it's it's
it it sucks a little energy out of you
so and players in their 20s overly
serious they they definitely have
physical advantage so older competitors
I probably would be able to play few
more years but I made a decision to
retire and it was not just overnight you
know what that did and the end of the
tournament in Spain in the city of
Linares but just beforehand I thought I
already made enough difference in the
game of chess so just making difference
was important I just recognized that
maybe it's time just to move on so just
just to start changing my life before
it's too late so you can't stay in chess
indefinitely because you need everybody
needs challenges so and I thought about
other challenges is there any universal
recipe for as success I don't think so I
think we all unique and it all depends
on us so what kind of ingredients and
the similar ingredients we'd like to put
into
Oh magic formula when we'll look at the
examples from from the history look at
the success stories we could find
different definition of success for
instance Mikhail Botvinnik the six world
champion known for his notoriety and
call the patriarch of Soviet chess
school probably the greatest scientists
in the history of chess so his formula
was very solid very much the ground
talent good health strong nerves
fighting spirit and good work ethic it
worked
Thomas Edison was even duller
he said success is 1% inspiration and
99% of perspiration
but Justina look at the different side
of equation Alexander Pushkin the
greatest russian poet considered to be
the father of the modern russian
language it's the man who was the
lightest touch of genius could produce
the best pieces of russian literature
ever he was a man of joy it was a
gambler he was even a rake always lived
in the red ink so his formula is quite
different a genius luck and experience
it also worked thank you so much for
watching I made this video because one
of you asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Garry Kasparov's top 10
rules meant the most to you leave it in
the comments below and I'll join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon